>> JONATHAN QUICK ZONE.
BENNETT, BACK TON THE GAME
PRODUCTIVE TO START THIS GAME
FOR THE KINGS.
THE 30TH GOALIE ALL-TIME TO
.
PICKS IT UP.
TREVOR MOORE WAS WAITING FOR TH
MISTAKE.
KNIGHT RECOVERED THE PUCUC OUT .
SPENCE OUT OF THE CORNER.
BACK TO EVEN STRENGTTHE
PANTHERS. A GAME THAT IS SO MAN
RIGHT FOR THE KINGS IN THAT
FIRST PERIOD, YOU GET A
THERE IS SOME WORRYO
EVERYWHERE.
>> AND IT'S EVERYBODY CORNER.
VILARDI TANGLES
YOU STEP BACK AND IT WAS DOOM
AND GLOOM FOR THE LAST TWO GAME
FOR THE KINGS.
BJORNFOT.,
BUT LET YOU GET INTO THE ZONE.
HE BARKS AT T A PIECE OF
IT.
CALLS THE
SO THIS OFFSIDE.E IN LOS ANGELE
WITH THE KIN WE'RE
ON TWITTER TONIGHT.
IAFALLO TURNS TO THE CORNER,
DEFENDED BY.
>> THIS IS JUST REMARKABLE ICE.
KNIGHT HIS LEGS AND ENDED UP
NOT.
DECISIVE.
WE SAW THAT S S
TREVOR DOESN'T HIT THE POST.